así después fueron exactamente 8 y ahora
89 estos 89 diputados recién electos que
de hecho hoy llegaron ya a la asamblea
nacional para llenar un digamos un
número de formalidades que hay que hacer
tanto ayer como hoy los diputados recién
electos pues han estado yendo allí para
llenar papeles para tomarse esa foto de
familia de digamos de cada una de las
agrupaciones políticas de usted bien lo
decía lo que quiere este partido pues es
mostrar que entró con fuerza y lo estaba
haciendo a la asamblea nacional ya de
por si está pidiendo la presidencia de
la comisión de finanzas normalmente esta
presidencia es para el partido que más
que más se digamos que la fuerza de
oposición más importante y en todo caso
pues según lo que según esas cifras esos
89 diputados normalmente eso le tocaría
a este esta reagrupación nacional porque
recordemos que la nube es una coalición
de partidos y no hay ninguno de los
partidos entre los insumisos ni tampoco
entre los socialistas ni los ecologistas
que logren tener una mayoría tan
grande como estos de los 89 así que
importante también el hecho de esa
presidencia de esa comisión porque eso
también puede digamos ponerle trabas a
cuando se vaya a votar el presupuesto
nacional a cada año así que más
problemas digamos para emanuel marco
como les decía hoy pues fue más la
intervención acompañó a todos estos
diputados ella lo que quiso fue también
guiarlos por todos esos recovecos y
caminos de la asamblea nacional que ella
conoce muy bien en todo caso les pidió
sobre todo cohesión y ejemplaridad